here's our take on developments brought
together from America the UK and around
the world smiles and handshakes is the
u.s. relationship with Israel in crisis
the murder of Nemtsov a sign of
deteriorating climate in Russia and
finally memories of the world's most
famous Vulcan there was a resounding
mixed reaction to the address to
Congress by the Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu President Obama
didn't watch he did read the transcript
and concluded there was nothing new
Nancy Pelosi said the speech was quote
an insult to the intelligence of the
United States the potential Republican
2016 candidate Jeb Bush tweeted this
powerful message from Netanyahu glad he
addressed Congress and detailed the
dangers of a nuclear Iran and this from
Senator Rand Paul I was pleased to hear
Netanyahu's speech today and will
continue to hashtag stand with Israel in
a moment we'll speak to David Harris
executive director of the American
Jewish Committee but first as usual the
Democrat commentator Geoffrey Robinson
is standing by for us in New York and
conservative commentator Armstrong
Williams is in Washington did you listen
to the speech Jeffrey or did you just
read it no I listened to it and I was
appalled absolutely appalled and I stand
with the 50 Democrats who didn't appear
walked out of the house and would not
sit there and listen to this first of
all it should never ever ever have
happened we have a standing tradition
that dates back all the way to George
Washington that we don't allow foreign
leaders to come to the house and
criticize foreign policy we use one
voice for foreign policy the house is
not there to negotiate on its own with
foreign leaders second of all mr.
Netanyahu made a campaign speech which
totally the lies all sorts of tradition
of political etiquette he was speaking
not only to the the Republicans who
wanted
to bash the president he was speaking to
a home audience running for reelection
this should never ever ever have
happened and I might remind you that mr.
Netanyahu is the Dick Cheney of Israeli
politics and we all know what problems
Dick Cheney created for the world mr.
Netanyahu is a prime minister who never
ever met a war he didn't want the US to
fight I'm strong did you listen to it it
is entirety and what do you make of it
you know I visited Israel on probably or
eight different occasions and his speech
brought about intense emotions with me
you know if the fact is the Iranian deal
which carry is in Switzerland now trying
to negotiate is just not in the best
interest of Israel the Middle East and
in the long run in the United States
even Senator Dianne Feinstein whose
chairs the committee said that she was
concerned about the ten years given to
our around and not fifteen years and I
felt sad Martin for Israel and that it
must face the prostate prospect of this
existential danger in the form of a
nuclear Fang Islamic theocracy and the
Iranian threat to the entire Middle East
and the entire world if we allow if we
allow ourselves to be short-sighted in
ill-advised is downright threatens all
existence Prime Minister Netanyahu is
not here to embarrass the president to
disrespect the president our country is
a pro-israel country we've had a long
history long relationships and while I
agree that the protocol he should have
fallen did not follow but in desperate
situations to make the American public
especially the legislative branch of
government our Congress realize that
they need to get involved in this debate
involved in these negotiations then that
what else and administration cannot
negotiate this alone there's too much at
stake even members of Congress on the
other side of the Democratic I'll heard
things they never heard before because
these talks have been in secrecy and so
while it's easy to lambast Netanyahu
let's not forget Netanyahu is not our
enemy it's Isis is Iran and he came to
bring that ply and that
message to American people and he was
welcome and we should have heard what he
had to say I'm stronger hold it there a
second Jeffrey wants to come back in and
I'll give him a chance but first let's
hear from David Harris who joins us now
from New York David this was an
unprecedented speech wasn't it in its
tone and in its opportunity that it
actually took place it was entirely
unprecedented that's correct I think an
American political diplomatic history I
know of no other similar occasion I was
meeting with the Prime Minister
privately in Jerusalem to 17 days ago as
he was thinking about coming and it was
clear to me that he felt he had to come
he had no choice he did not want to
politicize this no this was not an
electoral ploy as your guests suggested
rather he felt that the very existence
of Israel hung in the balance and he
felt he had no choice but to come to
Washington even in this unusual
circumstance and make the case of why
Israel's very existence hung in the
balance here and there for his voice
needed to be heard he feared that a bad
deal was coming he had access he said to
some of the information about the
negotiation and he felt that not only
Israel but the entire Middle East was at
risk and interesting i would add it's
noteworthy that a number of sunni arab
leaders and journalists have also come
out now come out of the closet and said
we don't agree with Prime Minister
Netanyahu on much but on the issue of
Iran we completely agree with him and
this by the way coincides with the
private meetings that we at a JC have
had with a number of Arab leaders who
have also expressed profound concern
both about Iran's role in the region and
about where this deal is currently
headed okay David but I want to ask you
this was it on prime ministerial in the
sense he wasn't representing all ranges
of opinion within Israel he was putting
his opinion there and he's Prime
Minister of the whole country not every
Israeli thinks there's an existential
threat from Iran today I think that's a
distinction without a difference to be
to be frank he is the democratically
elected got a leader of a democratic
government he came and he spoke as in
the role of Prime Minister by the way i
would add just as david cameron as prime
minister was in washington recently and
also took the unusual step together with
the White House of calling on a number
of legislators and urging them to to
support so there are a number of leaders
here who were quite involved in this but
but no one questions the fact that David
Cameron had the right to speak on behalf
of the UK even though he doesn't
necessarily represent every political
party Jeffrey is about to burst a blood
vessel if I don't let him talk Jeffrey
you disagree with a lot of what you just
heard all of it this is all smoke and
mirrors it was a political speech
because he's running for election and
the United States government should have
absolutely nothing to do with his
election it was a warmongering speech
intended to embarrass the president
Israel in the United States is not in
crisis we're in lockstep we understand
fully understand that there is a serious
threat from Iran and the president has
been working to make sure that they do
not get a nuclear weapon and his to
criticize the deal when there is no deal
nothing's written down there they're
negotiating it cuz I mean the whole
thing was wrong he should never ever
have been invited i might say that the
comment that david cameron came to
america and solicited legislators that's
fine but he didn't do it he didn't
criticize the president from the well of
the of the House of Representatives
that's not on that really is not on this
is a war mongering speech by a man who
was in crisis with the president that's
a personal disagreement but at no point
as the United States ever even suggested
that Iran is not a threat it is a threat
and we will always stand by Israel it's
whether or not anybody has any
credibility in the dick cheney of
Israeli politics but Jeffrey if this if
mr. Netanyahu has a genuine fear that
his country is being put in a real and
present danger doesn't have a duty as a
politician to speak out absolutely let
him do it on Meet the Press he has no
place in the House of Representatives
let him do what I meet the press let him
do it on Sky News let him do it on any
of the news programs they would give him
60 minutes he'd give him an hour but
it's not in the House of Representatives
where that should be done I'm stronger
is it the right place for this kind of
message absolutely and I think the
reason why Jerry and others are sorts
there is because Netanyahu
actually expose the NL and backwards way
of just the reality of the Obama
administration has been in it it's just
bent over backwards to a seat Iranians
demand at the negotiation table Jeffrey
can yell and scream to the top of the
mountain but most people who were not
for Netanyahu learned something they
understood that this is a crisis and who
better understands it than someone who
lives with that threat and that crisis
every day and as David said Arabs
Palestinians privately have said no
matter what they may think about Israel
and Netanyahu Iran is a threat to
everyone and even though I ran fights
Isis like we fight Isis they fight for
different reasons ok this is a serious
threat and we keep hearing voices like
like Jeffrey who speaks in condemn
Netanyahu Netanyahu is not the issue
here it's the fact that Iran should be
stopped from gathering a win to build
nuclear weapons it's a threat to the
world no one is dawn is arguing that
Netanyahu shouldn't speak out no one is
arguing that it's not a threat it is a
threat what I'm saying is he had no
place doing it in the House of
Representatives it was a political
speech aimed at embarrassing Obama and I
blame that directly on the thug the Jane
John Boehner is a speaker of the house
he is a look Darris let me bring you
back in the conversation here is this
kind of rather shouting diplomacy
because it you couldn't get a bigger
stage could you than Congress is this
effective or is a more subtle a more
bat-channel conversation with Iran and
doing a deal which then eventually is
exposed to the world it's not a better
route to take despite what your guest
has said this was not a warmongering
speech to the contrary Prime Minister
Netanyahu went to great lengths to say
that he felt a better deal could be
achieved no one wants war and to simply
try and characterize him as the Israeli
Dick Cheney to me is is a bit of a
stretch in fact the room was filled
yesterday with both Democrats and
Republicans yes some Democrats
regrettably chose not to show up but
three-fourths of the democrats were
there and all the Republicans were there
so there was a bipartisan expression
of support for what happened again the
Prime Minister felt that this was not
about electioneering this was about a
kind of diplomatic Hail Mary that said
my country's very existence is under
threat seventy years after the end of
the Holocaust when people who said they
wanted to destroy the Jewish people did
what they said despite the fact that
many in the world refused to believe
them at the time David Holladay says we
are in general without Israel Jeffrey no
David you're dead wrong dead wrong David
this was not bipartisan support for a
warmongering speech and the insult of
the president this was people sitting
there listening that doesn't mean they
supported second of all he never said
anything new there was nothing
substantial in his speech except
warmongering a political speech and
insulting the president he never came up
with solutions he said well we have to
keep negotiating that's all he said we
know about the threat we believe in the
threat we understand the threat he
should have done it on Meet the Press it
would have been a lot more effective
instead what he did was he insulted the
United States government by teaching us
what's really happening which is
nonsense because we all know and John
Boehner should be ashamed of himself for
allowing this travesty to happen
absolutely ashamed of himself David
Harris can I just move this on how do
you think this discussion red hot topic
this week will impact on the election
campaign as candidates start to jostle
from both parties well I can always
speak about the American Jewish
community and and in the American Jewish
community you may have two forces of
work pulling in somewhat opposite
directions that is most American Jews
some 75 percent on average tend to vote
for the Democratic presidential
candidate that was the case in 2012 2008
and going back again with some
variations on the other hand I think the
fact that that there's been such strong
support to the Republican Party for
Israel for the prime minister again i
want to add not just in the republican
party despite what your guest keeps
saying many democrats yesterday stood
applauded and supported what happened
but nonetheless there's going to be that
that attempt by the republican party to
play on these themes to say we are the
party that supports Israel and they're
going to try and pull an American
voters the one thing that we have
learned over many years of polling at a
JC is American Jews are not single-issue
voters and whether the Democrats or the
Republicans tried to appeal to American
Jews on the basis of one issue even an
issue as important as Israel they're
unlikely to succeed Jews are
sophisticated voters they're going to be
multi-issue voters and they're going to
look at the range of issues and the
range of personalities on both sides of
the aisle before before pulling that
lever in 2016 David Harris thank you for
joining us from New York today
now what is the state of Russian now
what is the state of Russian opposition
now that a leading opponent of Vladimir
Putin has been killed does the murder on
the streets of Moscow mean that the
hopes of Boris Nemtsov supporters may
have died with him well let's talk to
Moscow's Dimitri gud off a leading
independent MP in the Duma Dimitri is
opposition in Russia dead yeah the first
leeway to demand transparent
investigations and today yes i demanded
the proline into investigation of this
matter I think that it should be placed
by the elementary control we need to
wait a month this murder to be solved
and I think that we need to understand
and we need to realize what's happened
because you know it's a political murder
and it changed our country drastically
for example if recently we can be
threatened by being jailed oh but today
it's a very dangerous just to walk
around this in there in the city on the
street so everything depends on who
ordered this murder if it's ordered by
the Kremlin authorities it's a it's a
big problem in the future for the future
events let's bring in Armstrong Williams
and Jeffrey as well standing by New York
Armstrong let's go to you first on this
one are you confident that there will be
a fair and truthful investigation to
what took place well I got to tell you
whatever his death his cattle relies
Martin a real mass movement against
Putin's authoritarian rules remains to
be seen there's a very good reason for
Russians to be angry but I got a taste
of Putin has put in rules where people
who decide to protests or jail they
disappear so people are under the veil
of a real anti-protest a movement there
I mean people have been in prison and so
it doesn't have the kind of climate if
you look at
but they are expressing their not really
expressing anger they're expressing
sadness and they're also expressing a
fear of the authoritarian rule and
growing power of Putin in that part of
the world and how this plays out even
our guest is being very careful in his
word selection and what he says and
understandably so because you know he
risked his only his life his well-being
his family I think if we just listen to
the guest listen how he expressed
himself they have to be very careful
we're not in that country without in
issues there's no doubt in the eyes and
the minds of many people that Putin and
his cronies were behind this
assassination they can't say that he was
he was a holdover from Yeltsin cabinet
his authority had drastically clients
and Putin came to power Putin wanted to
get rid of him and he did Geoffrey
Robinson what does this say about modern
Russia to you modern Russia under mr.
Putin is a mafia cracy short and simple
and this is what mafias do they
eliminate any of any resistance to their
rule I totally agree with Armstrong and
I and I think that Dimitri good off is
being very brave to appear on the
program and good for you Dimitri but
this is not the first time this has
happened this has happened in the past
and perhaps Dimitri will address that
and talk about some of the other
assassinations I fear that what will
happen is they'll come up with some sort
of a scapegoat and they will say it was
up it was a love triangle or something
like that but let me say one thing
whatever their excuse is and whatever
the the Kremlin puts out as being the
reason behind this the very first thing
that any really good criminal
investigator does and the very first
thing that any investigative journalist
does is say there is no such thing as
coincidence I guarantee you it is not a
coincidence that this man was who he was
and that he got into Putin's face and
Putin decided I don't like that to be
triggered off in Moscow is it a scary
place to be do you fear if not for your
life for your future as a politician no
of course
so we feel we experienced a fill of
concern threat and feel of shock of
course it's very it's very difficult
just to focus some political future in
Russia because I know we actually split
late because but he's being talked about
the part of this ellipse he was the
deputy prime minister he was the member
of state parliament and of course
everyone is shocked in Russia ah I know
that many people in dumont they are also
feel threatened because you know we've
been living in the atmosphere of hate
because of the propaganda and this
machine of hatred can hit tomorrow can
hit the people who created it so
everyone is shocked and of course there
is an understanding that we need to find
a way out of this situation but
everything depends on one figure in
Russia so I hope that will never it
never comes a happen again in Russia and
I hope that there are there are some
smart people in the lead and they will
try to influence on Putin just to change
policy because it's impossible it's very
dangerous can i widen this out from just
this murder because one of the theories
Armstrong let me bring you in on this
was this was a connection to the
Ukrainian dispute that itself as we've
discussed on this program before is a
very thorny issue some don't like what
mr. Putin is doing there some believe
he's completely in the wrong the West
thinks he's in the wrong with the
sanctions and this is a very febrile
atmosphere could this be playing into
this murder too you know I think there's
so much that is intertwined in this
murder and I think it shows Putin's
mindset I think Putin Putin feels that
he's fearless he has control he has the
country under his grip you've not seen
these
kind of protest since I think what's
what 2011-12 after he was elected to
office and he almost should have called
himself czar and then the people reacted
there was such a backlash in such
negativity about how those elections to
handle and I think even though that was
a protest that got his attention I think
since that day what Putin is convinced
himself up is that nothing like that in
his country will ever happen again and
anybody who feels that kind of
speculation to bring about that kind of
backlash he will take them out he was
solace them he will imprison them and I
think for people for fear of life and a
well-being and a family I think the
atmosphere is that we will go along
until we do better but like Jeffrey said
this is a mafia OSIS mentality he has
total control total domination he has
billions of dollars to back it up and a
government surrounding who I mean in
fear not to get in his way Jeffrey yeah
it's a mafia cracy but I'd like to hear
Dimitri good off talk about the other
political assassinations because this is
just one in a string of them Dimitri um
yeah I think it's one of the string
because just we remember for example
politkovskaya she was the report of
nowhere as yet it's in one of
independent newspaper frost sure I can
remember some member of Parliament's
Tara wait awhile you should cough and
this murder haven't been solved so but
for example we know just people who kill
for example you should go but we don't
know people holder and it's uh I think I
think that it's you know one of the
murder in the line of in the line of
this political assassination Dimitri
thank you very much indeed Dimitri good
off independent MP in the gym but thanks
for joining us from Moscow
finally this week two years ago the
movie star trek into darkness was
released and here on the red carpet at
the premiere was Leonard Nimoy in his
last performance as it turned out as
Spock as you know he passed away this
week let's get a couple of reflection
shall we from Jeffrey and from Armstrong
Jeffrey I hear you can do that that
split finger salute thing I've been
practicing I can't there it is there it
is live well and prosper you're a proper
tragedies any what aight i'll tip well
i'm not a Trekkie but i'll tell you what
made leonard nimoy absolutely unique in
show business he played the same
character for what are we now talking
three generations mmm in both television
and on film you look at some of the
other actors who have played one
character for their entire career
basically for their entire career they
think of Richard Belzer playing
detective munch on homicide and law and
order special victims unit and I think
of Kelsey Grammer playing frasier on
cheers and Frasier but they didn't
translate that into cinema also and and
Leonard Nimoy did so besides being a
much-loved character who had a great
influence on several generations he also
goes down as may be the only actor to
have ever played one character for his
entire career in both television and
film and that's worth the saloon haha it
sure is um I'm strong incense it could
have been a really difficult role to get
right wasn't it that rather deadpan that
logical way of thinking great writing
but he really brought the part to life
oh yeah he brought it alive look he heat
unleashed his own take extreme these
Sparky pointed ears are the flat
hairline um and you know it he was just
a character of our times but you know I
tell you what's interesting you say
there's nothing bad and I'm not gonna
say anything bad about it but I will
tell you as someone who's really likes
photography and paintings I actually
followed much of his which is so under
torti his photography career I don't
know if you knew about his depiction of
Jews and Jewish women and men clothing
which caused such a backlash among the
Jewish people in which whom he loved so
much and yet his rabbi defending him but
I thought his creativity in terms of
photography even though it was
controversy is phenomenal the way his
mind worked and it kind of photos that
he would take another thing he would do
he would take photos of underrated
people people that he thought society
did not care much about he would focus
on their sexuality he would focus on a
beast people and I would encourage
people listening to this broadcast to
get away from Captain Nemo and look at
his incredible contribution of
photography and just see so many kinds
of things that he created along the way
I'm strong great way to finish the show
thank you very much indeed I'm strong
and Jeffrey live long and prosper both
of you see the same time same place next
week because that's it for this edition
of the debate you can continue watching
sky news on apple TV on roku on catch up
and of course at Sky News com until next
time goodbye